so I wanted to start with just a couple
polling questions here and the first
question is not talking about canvas
course reserves the first question
pertains to your standard traditional
library course reserves where you put
books or you put films and or other
documents and they end up on a shelf and
you go down and leave it there for the
students okay so actually many of you
haven't okay well that's the traditional
way of if you want to make books that
you're using in your class or other
texts or multimedia items such as films
available you can assign a film where
you can sign a book maybe the students
don't want to buy the book they can go
to the library and they can check it out
from the course reserve so that's the
traditional way and that's what I have
used you know up until this this past
year myself okay so the next so let's
move on to the next slide here oh I see
you have to do it this way okay so if
you've used it what kinds of items have
you used it for
okay so mostly books but a little bit of
some other things so that's for myself
all of the above would apply I tend to
use quite a few different course
reserves for my classes okay so moving
on let me just talk about why I ended up
here giving this talk today and part of
the reason is when I started teaching
here of course I had to prepare my
classes and which meant as you know
accumulating all kinds of readings and
resources and so forth for the students
and teaching a lot of classes that also
deal with Southeast Asian Studies meant
that I had to find a lot of items that
are not always readily available so you
know often if I'm using like a Southeast
Asian film quite you know it's not
always going to be the case that it's
going to be in the library so I was
spending an amazing amount of time
through emails with the librarians
trying to track down all these different
sources and then so I was tracking them
through all these emails and it was a
little unwieldy and they were emailing
back and forth and I was keeping my
lists and sending them updated list and
then finally one of the library and said
why don't you use canvas course reserves
and I was like oh well I had no idea
really what that was so I went in and
had a look at it and much to my delight
I discovered this is really great I had
no idea that such a thing existed and so
that's what I'm going to talk to you and
show you briefly how to use today and
talk to you about some of the benefits
of this so just quickly how many of you
have used the e research have used
canvas course reserves okay just almost
nobody okay oh wait a minute oh this is
changing rapidly so a lot of you have
used it okay that really didn't really
turned around very quickly okay so I'm
going to talk to you just show you for
those of you who haven't what's there
and I'm going to share with you some of
the things that I found particularly
useful about it so
right so this is just one of my courses
this is a seminar mass violence in
Southeast Asia mass violence and it's
aftermath and this just shows a small
portion of it but what you can see here
is that you know the first three items
on there are films the fourth item on
there that you can see is actually a
book and that's actually my book but it
comes in both two forms it is available
as an electronic reserve in the library
it's also available as a hardcopy
and the one of the really great things
about course reserves and adding
everything onto your list here is that
you can include both hardcopy things
where people can go down to the library
if they want the hard copy or if only a
hard copy is available but they can also
just go to that item then once it's in
here and one of the great things is that
it's not only you that are accessing
these things but you can make this
available to your students so they can
find everything that they need for your
course or at least most things that what
you'd put on reserves in one place so
the beauty of that is that for things
especially like films if there are a lot
of them now are electronically available
maybe they're on canopy or something
like that they can just simply click on
it and watch it or if you want to play
it in your class you couldn't just go to
course razor find it quickly and watch
it you don't have to go looking it up or
anything so I'm going to just walk you
through it in just a minute but I just
want to call your attention to that
subscribe now button that you see on
there that subscribe now I don't know if
you can't my mouse doesn't show it up in
the corner that's so if you're a student
you can subscribe to the to the course
reserves that way and you'll get updates
on whenever your professor puts new
things on there ok so here's the bottom
of the list you see that big button add
reserve items that's one of the ways
that you can add reserve items so let me
just go now to I'm gonna go in one
second to show you how it's done but
first just so you know if you want
instructions on how to do court
research it's all available here at this
website and I notice there's a form of a
document over there that has all that
information as well so okay so this is
we're gonna do this oops that's the
wrong thing live here now okay so this
is see if I can maximize that okay so
this is now I'm in the course reserve so
let's say I want to add another item
there's two ways I can do that one is I
can go here through this class tools and
I can say add reserve items or I could
press that button that I showed you
before in the beginning so I'm just
gonna do that here now add reserve item
so this is what it looks like and it
says here you can add an article or book
chapter on IRA's ERV and what that is
briefly is you can request a particular
book chapter and they will go through
the scan and put it in there for you
it's really great or you can just put
the article in and they will collect it
from the library or you can share the
call number the second is it could be a
physical reserve as I mentioned such as
a book or it could be a DVD or you can
say it's an audio-visual item so once
you put that in then you need to fill in
this information which is all pretty
clear and then you get to this and they
just change this this copyright or fair
use thing you have to select one of
these that and that basically says that
you have the right for that copyright
and generally most of the time the top
one is going to be they want the correct
one because the libraries already worked
through all the agreements so I that's
my approach and so then they have this
thing here which says you could tag the
item I I don't tend to use the the tag
the item too much because the way they
say it's useful is that you could tag it
like these are the readings for week 1
these are the readings for week 2 if you
want to use
those same items and for another class
then you can end up in a situation that
everything's missed tagged because you'd
be using it for for the other class
because you can transfer over your
course reserves from one course into
another which is very nice so you don't
have to enter all that information again
so that's and then down here you have
where can I find this item you can
upload it yourself it's already online
I'll bring a copy in or let's find it
I found that let's find it button to be
really really helpful and the great
thing is they go out and they look for
it and then then you know inside the
your list of courses and it'll give you
the status of whether they found it yet
so it's like still pending or Dulce and
I've had a case where they where it just
simply wasn't available and they just
say it's not available
it'll or it'll say it's or it'll just be
there and that's useful for your
students also be especially if you
something comes up where you want to add
something during the course they can see
when it's coming on so I've had that
happen where like a new film or
something has come out on something and
I've wanted to add it so that's really
useful so that's most of it in a
nutshell I strongly encourage you to use
it and I don't think I have any time for
questions do I okay well I'll be
available over there afterwards so thank
you very much
you